it's absolutely the very beginning of
providing monetization opportunities to
diviners who have done such great work
at building this unique community of
content creators and connecting them to
brands we think it's just going to be
awesome for the brands who want to
leverage the great work these finders do
to create stories and for the Viners who
are able to then build a career off all
the fun things they're able to do with
the platform do you find yourself
competing with snapchat for this new
generation of video creators I think
about it more as this unique platform
we've developed in vine and this awesome
you know there are these stop motion
animation experts there are these
comedians there are these sort of vine
magicians through some of the frame by
frame animation work they do and being
able to leverage their talents to help
brands and companies tell their stories
across the Twitter ecosystem we think is
really cool and by bringing a niche on
board we think we're gonna be able to do
that not just on vine but across the
broader Twitter ecosystem meaning within
Twitter itself as well there there is so
much energy right now around the vine
ecosystem and snapchat as well it makes
me wonder whether YouTube has squandered
some of the opportunity around mobile
video do you see them in the mobile
videos there are gonna be lots of
players in this native mobile video
space and again but by native mobile I
say that a lot and what I mean when I
say that is video primarily a produced
for consumption on mobile we led the way
there with fine
we just think there's an enormous amount
of opportunity there and buying niche
was part of realizing that opportunity
we're gonna do a lot more there as well
well a couple of weeks ago my Android
Twitter app updated itself to allow for
native video mobile video like so what
as that as those tools have rolled out
to users what kind of usage have you
seen what kind of consumption we've seen
great usage of them I think one of the
things we've been fascinated about in
just the first couple weeks is how much
people are using native mobile video to
reply to tweets so someone will text
texts you know write a text tweet and
mention another user on Twitter and that
user will reply with a video short video
we've seen that from individual users
like Gary Vaynerchuk has been doing that
a lot we've seen it from companies
medium has been doing a sort of a QA
using native mobile video and their
responses we just did a QA today with
with Amy Schumer and comedian Amy
Schumer was written and starring in this
movie that's coming out the summer
trainwreck she did all her responses via
video so I think that's really cool and
you know wouldn't have been the first
use case we anticipated but it's neat to
see that kind of blowing up so let me
ask you about user growth recently in
your quarterly earnings report user
growth was a little bit down but you
expressed a confidence that it would
come back up to the level seen in
previous quarters why are you so sure
well you know we did that in the very
first week of February and so we had the
benefit of having seen what was
happening in January and as we mentioned
that outlook was based on seeing a
return to organic growth growth
initiatives that we've had inside the
company that are delivering results and
then some seasonality where q1 has just
seasonally higher than q4 traditionally
you've you've increased the cadence of
product launches recently a big one is
instant time I talked a little bit about
that and why it's important sure I mean
one of the things that you know I've
been I've been talking about since we
were on the IPO Roadshow is bridging
that gap between awareness of Twitter
and really engaged on Twitter and part
of that gap is new users have come to
the platform they just saw it on TV they
just saw this thing is happening it's
all on Twitter right now head over there
they sign up for the platform and then
they can't find the right accounts to
follow they don't understand how to use
it etc instant timeline is about
delivering immediate value to these
users the moment they sign up removing
the follow friction from the way they
get value out of the platform right away
and getting them a great timeline of 20
40 90 accounts to look at immediately
and show them how to use the platform
not try to teach them how to use the
platform another area of focus is
messaging I'm still terrified to send a
message on Twitter I feel like I'm gonna
blast it to my whole network
what's the ultimate vision for messaging
on Twitter it's being able to take a
public conversation private because we
believe that when you see these public
conversations and you participate in
them there's a tremendous use case for
taking that conversation to a private
channel whether it's between you and a
company how many times do you see people
talk about hey I'm late for my I missed
my flight at Delta at Virgin America at
United please help me they respond with
hey follow us and we'll DM you and being
able to take all that context of any
public conversation between two accounts
to a private channel between one or more
of those accounts we think is just a
huge opportunity both for businesses and
users on Twitter and then also look
there just times when you see a public
conversation on Twitter and you want to
have a sidebar conversation with you and
your friends about this thing that's
happening publicly that's fun so this is
about enabling that and enhancing it to
make Twitter increasingly a daily use
case for people now the product key
behind some of these new features you've
had some instability on the team some
managers coming in and going because
that situation stabilized so the short
answer is yes I love the team that we
have in place I've also been
particularly enthused by the way my
direct reports are building out their
bank bench and strengthening their bench
and bringing other leaders into the
company we've just had a couple more
additions to our engineering leadership
just in the last week so that's
something I'm enthusiastic about and
excited about look their organizations
are always going to evolve and change
over time but I really like the team we
feel like you made mistakes in previous
incarnations of the team I think I
always tell my leaders inside the
company it's your job to always be
improving your team and there are all
sorts of things you can do to improve
your team your job is not to defend your
team your job is to improve your team
and so that's something I focused on and
paid careful attention to and I love the
way the team is set up now I was struck
by the internal statement that you made
about rolling on Twitter recently you
said that the whole world knows that
this bullying behavior happens on the
network we haven't done enough to stop
it what do you want to see the ordered
yeah let me just start off by saying
that was I think the first time I used
the word we suck at this in a used to
crass language like that and a
company-wide email of course that's the
one that gets leaked not one of my more
sophisticated writing memos um look the
point of writing that note to the
company was to let them know I take
responsibility for that
we're not just going to go ahead with
the status quo anymore we're going to
get a lot more aggressive it's on me to
make sure we do that and we're gonna be
aggressive and fast about making changes
so that was about me putting the sort of
weight on my shoulders if you will and
letting the rest of the company know
we're gonna get more aggressive here and
quickly
okay ecommerce on Twitter I feel like
Amazon has been trying to sell me the
same portable USB charger since he
introduced the feature on the network
what's the ultimate vision and how big
can it be we're still experimenting
there I've said a number of times that I
think the opportunity for Twitter is to
really be the place for in the moment
commerce now Commerce in the context of
seeing some public conversation oh yeah
I want that and I get it now as distinct
from other kinds of Commerce that are
just here's a catalogue of stuff so we
have a number of experiments we're
running there we're learning a ton from
running those experiments we don't have
anything new to announce I think you'll
continue to see us explore with
different kinds of what does now
commerce really mean in the coming
months and we'll see what happens okay a
long-term question Facebook of course is
1.2 billion users a 200 billion dollar
market cap is your vision for Twitter
still on the is it on the same par as at
Facebook's scale I think our vision for
Twitter is to have the largest possible
audience the largest daily audience in
the world we believe that Twitter is a
value and can be a value to every
connected person on the planet and
that's the strategy we're delivering
against we think that total audience
strategy is comprised of strengthening
the core of logged in users but also
organizing content experiences for that
more than half billion users a month who
come to Twitter and don't login and
syndicating those content experiences
across the entirety of the web and
mobile landscape okay dick maybe to wrap
up on a light note we're here at a
financial conference your CFO Anthony
Noto
perhaps some good natured ribbing his
his Twitter account got hacked recently
does what's going on does does he need a
tutorial and two-factor authentication
yeah and he received a particularly
compelling offer from a Nigerian prince
those are harder harder is this I'll
just leave it at that